Hello, this is Lynn. Someone on the other side of this. Hey,
so a couple months ago, our producer Lynn Levy,
did an interview with this woman. Yeah. Her name is Margaret. Love it. Yes.
And this was Margaret's first time doing a radio interview.
That magic voice. This is so fun,
but this was definitely not her first time talking into a microphone. One, two,
three, four. This is the yellow mine. Frank, two three, four.
This is the orange mind almost exactly 50 years ago.
The following recording was made on November,
1919 64 at 2100 hours.
Margaret was epicenter of this amazing, weird experiment.
Yeah. Who were you at that time? Like what were you like? Well, I,
I've always had a bit of, if everybody's going left, I'll go right.
She tried college for a while, too, lane university for a year,
but she dropped out and I was 20 or 19 or something at that point and moved to
St Thomas in the Caribbean. Had never been turned Ireland.
Got a job at this hotel. Did Menus check people in and out?
And one day she hears about this strange research facility on the other side of
the island. And I thought, I wonder what that is about.
And I asked a few people and they said, oh no, no,
they don't like people there can't go there. And I was told not to go there.
So I went there.
Mm.
And that's how it all started. That's how we're going to start this show.
I'm Jab. I'm Ron, I'm Robert Krulwich. Today on Radio Lab,
a producer Lynn Levy brings us a couple of close encounters.
Although not with aliens. No, it's not.
It's not in outer space because it's much closer to home in this case.
Although they are kind of alien, like yes, but alien life, uh, not
Lynn Dolphin shows about dolphins. Hey,
we're calling this our hello. So when Margaret got to this mysterious place,
there were dolphins there and uh, the,
what happened was she ended up becoming roommates with the Dolphin.
Do you mean in the like Bed-Stuy one bedroom apartment sense? Sort of. Yeah.
She did end up living with a dolphin for,
for many months in this apartment,
a big apartment party. Had a little desk,
had a little kitchen area with a stove.
It was a little two burner stove or something and a pop, a kettle.
But the thing that's a little bit weird about the apartment is that the whole
apartment was filled with water, was completely filled.
Well I wasn't submerged, but I was in water up mid five,
sort of flooded with water just about there so she could share it with this
dolphin. A young male, Peter, Peter,
Peter was a 10 foot long bottlenose dolphin, young adolescent male.
And he lived there with Margaret and like he would, um, you know,
he could like swim under the desk and uh, there was a balcony,
like swim out onto the balcony and balcony was flooded to the balcony was also
flooded. Yeah, it's really cool. And what was the idea?
I mean to try and study the dolphin to study the dolphin, um, first of all,
and take a lot of notes, extensive
notes. Did you have waterproof paper? No,
I had a typewriter on this board hanging from the ceiling or they also had
microphones everywhere. And specifically the tasks she was given.
I was to teach Peter to speak English.
She was supposed to teach the dolphin English. Yup. Really? Well,
I mean this was John Lilly's project.
[inaudible]
just for some context,
you know how people get all like a little bit crazy these days about dolphins.
They have like, you know,
shirts with dolphins and necklaces with dolphins and everybody has like dolphin
hairbands, dolphin, black light posters, right.
So this all kind of sort of comes from this Guy John Lilly,
who was a scientist, a researcher starting in the forties
total rights stuff, physics major kind of guy out of Caltech
man's man. According to Graham Burnett, I'm a historian of science.
But then according to Graham, John Lilly has this epiphany
during the second world war.
At the time people just weren't thinking that much about dolphins in general.
Like there was not this idea that they were sort of extraordinary beings.
They were just like big dumb fish, you know, they were shot for sport.
So John Lilly is doing this, um,
research about brain mapping and he ends up working with dolphins and when the,
the story that he's told goes that he was experimenting on these dolphins and as
he's working with them, you know, kind of like shoving things into their brains.
They make noises as would anyone.
And when he listens back to the noises which he's recorded,
it sounds to him like the dolphins are trying to speak to him to say something
to him in not in a non, in a dolphin e way,
but in a human way. Like trying to speak English to him. Really. Yeah.
What did he say the Dolphin was trying to say to him?
I don't think that we know that,
but it sounded to him enough like human speech that he,
he thought like something's going on here. This is important.
According to Graham, he's said later that it made him realize like we're in
not the only intelligent organisms out there,
like we have company that maybe humans are what happens when high intelligence
evolves in an animal that also has hands and dolphins are what happens when
comparably if not still more extravagant intelligence evolves in an animal
without him.
Oh, what do hands get you?
Well, our hands basically get you an appetite for uh,
punching people in the head. You know,
it makes us tool users, but the distance between, uh, you know,
the hammer that you use to uh,
knock open your coconut and the hammer that you use to knock open the head of
that other cro-magnon you were never that keen on is um, in fact, zilch.
There's no difference at all.
By the time we get to the 60s with, you know, like peace and love.
It was exciting to think that the dolphins and the whales have these huge
brains, but they don't, like, they're not after anything.
They're not doing anything with it. They're not trying to hurt anybody.
They're not building cities. They're just like being a man
and keep in mind,
this is on the verge of the Vietnam War where you have all this anxiety about
two, the air overpopulation, environmental destruction,
what have they done to our fair system?
So very quickly the dolphins become like this vision
of how we might ourselves be so different than we'd come to feel we were
tragically. Does that make sense?
So John Louis was one of the first people to get swept up in all this.
He quits his government job, moves to the Caribbean and sets up this lab.
John Lilly's communication research institute to try to talk to dolphins,
which is where Margaret ended up. And my feeling was this or that.
Everybody was talking about how bright they were and how smart they were.
And it was dolphins, dolphins, dolphins, and then it was, it was the hot topic.
And yet every day everybody at that building would get in their car and go home.
Yeah, on a foot. What is that? So she volunteered to stay. Yeah. Yeah.
Her bed was on this kind of wooden platform in the middle of the apartment.
I was maybe two and a half,
three inches above the water and Peter was right there and Peter could flip me a
little water and wake me up at any point. And that was the whole point of it.
I mean this wasn't just sleep all night and then, excuse me,
work in the day and then sleep again all night and then do some work in the day.
I might as well go home. Yeah. So I eventually, um,
I didn't really shave my head but I buzzed it,
whatever it's called now really close because any,
you know the hair getting wet thing in the middle of the night was very
annoying. Yeah, of course. I just got rid of her hair and that was helpful.
And then when Peter would come and squirt some water or want to play or throw
something at me,
then I could just roll off this elevator into the water and be with him and do
whatever she says. He was fascinated by the things she brought with her.
A piece of cloth, a tea bag, tea bag was a fascinating thing.
I drank,
I drink tea and the tea bag would fall into the water and he would come and get
it. And Sonar at, uh,
this creaking noise they make on their sonar.
And you'd look at it and take the string over his beak,
sort of whim around very proudly with this teabag.
And then he'd throw it up against the wall and it would stick.
And then he'd squirt water on it and it would come back down into the water and
he would play with this teabag. Eventually, of course, he would, would bite.
It is very sharp teeth. Yeah. And it would break.
And that was a very exciting thing when the teabag finally broke open.
It had babies, as it were, zillions of tea leaves floating around.
And he was so, not of them all in one count, every single one of them.
[inaudible]
and what did you think you would find out? I didn't know.
You know,
I was not coming at this from a science point of view that that's not what I was
bringing to the table. Yeah. I just, I just, I just, I had no idea. I,
I was, uh, programmed by, by John to work on the speech.
[inaudible] I all he had sort of declared that they could probably speak
Aye.
[inaudible]
look when, when you're trying to have a conversation with someone
when you do listen, uh,
one person speaks and the other one listens and then you're speaking and I
listen. And people sort of normally do that back and forth.
When you start with a dolphin making airborne sounds, once they get the idea,
this alarm is, it goes
the very show. Offy and they want to override you.
So you have to spend a lot of time getting it down to I'm talking now. Right.
Wow.
And now it's your turn.
[inaudible]
now any other Fuze upset about something, he'll override
pater and it's annoying. Yeah. Listen again.
[inaudible]
Hey, what's this? Come on Peter. One, two,
three.
[inaudible]
no, start again. One, two, three.
yes, but he learned very quickly to listen to me. One, two, three, four
[inaudible]
woo.
And not to pick up my instructions if I would say, no, no, no,
Peter, I don't want you to do that. I want you to do this, this,
this, Huh? He would give me back this, this,
this parrot will often say, no, no, no, probably want to crack her.
They will Pete, the whole thing of whatever you said. Huh.
But Peter Wood would pick up what I wanted when he was being a good student and
he was a good student. There seemed to be
with this one dolphin anyway, can speak for all of them. An interest in,
in what we were doing. He wanted to practice, he wanted to get it right.
He a, there was a mirror and he would spend long periods of time by himself.
Didn't want me to be part of it.
And he would practice whatever it was we had been in the lesson that day over
and over and over and over. He wanted to get it right.
Yeah.
And he, he would work at that for no reason. He's not getting fish.
I'm not interacting with them and nothing. He just wants it. Right.
Like doing homework, like homework.
Exactly.
And after a few months of this,
Peter did start to sound really different.
One two
[inaudible]
one, two, three.
yeah, they're [inaudible].
He kept getting better. It's an extremely difficult for them.
Oh,
they just have a blow hole. They,
they do have the apparatus to where the s's are almost impossible.
Uh, I would feed him my name and m is very hard.
He would eventually roll over almost into the water with the blow hole to
muffle.
No
kind of a thing. Really. You're saying he would,
he would use the water as a way to help him make the sound. Yes.
I'll work with that word.
[inaudible]
and he knew that was your name.
I don't know.
But nevertheless, we were a pretty good match. He,
I, I knew his mood, his temperament, and he, and he knew mine.
He knew when I was sick and I would get sick and you're in the water all the
time. You're bound to get a cold or something. He, he just loved my anatomy.
He wanted to know what my knees were doing.
He would go behind my knee and sonar and look at it and feel it and push it and
find out which way it wouldn't, wouldn't go. He just, and I gave him the time
cause I wasn't going home to look at my knee to look at my feet.
He was enormously interested,
oddly enough in the space between my fingers.
Really not the fingers so much, but he would, I mean, you know,
his beat could just barely fit there,
but he wanted to put in between each finger and see what that was all about.
The same with the toes. He didn't have any spaces anywhere. He, you know,
he had solid flippers but no space in between them.
Do you think he was so interested in your fingers and toes because he didn't
have any? Yes, I do.
Margaret and Peter ended up spending about nine months living together,
but towards the end things kind of started to, first
of all, they weren't really results from this experiment.
They never were able to publish any scientific papers and there were other
problems. Lily got very involved in drugs, especially
LSD. He did bring it down.
He did a give LSD. He says he did.
I believe him to to, to have that arms. I would not let him give LSD to Peter.
I wouldn't allow that. Why would he give them,
well it's not a hundred percent clear,
but it seems like he was trying to find a way to get the dolphins to open up to
connect,
maybe to talk in any case by 1965 66,
his funding had started to dry up. And when people heard about Margaret's work,
they tended to focus on like one particular part of the story.
You don't have to answer,
but a lot has been made of your uh ha sort of sexually engaging with Peter.
And I just want to ask, cause you don't seem like a shrinking violet.
I just want to ask, is there anything you want to say about that?
Um, what would I like to say about that? I think
the sensational side of it is,
here's what Margaret told me. Peter was a young dolphin,
he was horny and he would hump her leg a lot, kind of like a dog might do,
which was getting in the way of their work.
So eventually I just said the heck with it. And she used her hand to,
you know, and,
and it would quickly satisfy him and then we could go back to doing what we were
doing. And I, I never really gave it another thought. I never thought, Oh,
don't let anybody know. I never thought, oh, this shouldn't be.
But because of details like this and the drugs,
this experiment became extremely controversial,
almost untouchable. People didn't want to be associated with Lilly.
Nobody wanted to fund anything that sounded like Lilly.
It just got this like aura of don't go there,
don't go there.
Even people who wanted to do really rigorous work with human dolphin
communication had a tough time getting any funding.
And that lasted for a long time.
And the thing is,
even though there are so many reasons to disapprove of this experiment,
when you talk to Margaret,
you can't read each other's company help but want to be in that apartment with
them.
He would come over and when he was in what I call his sweet mood and Peter had a
lot of very, very sweet mood to him.
He would sink to the bottom and take my foot in his mouth and he wasn't so
knowing and he wasn't looking at anything.
It was almost like a little kid comes and just wants to hold your hand and he
would just sink to the bottom and close his eyes and just hang onto my foot.
Okay.
And then you'd have to come up and breathe and then you'd go back down and he
just grabbed my foot.
Um,
and he would do this for all a good while. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we'll be back in a moment with another encounter.
You have two new messages. Hi, this is d Graham Burnett. Yes.
Hi, this is Margaret [inaudible]. Here we go.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and the Alfred
p Sloan Foundation enhancing public understanding of science and technology in
the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org Radiolab is produced by W N Y C and
distributed by NPR. I think that's it. I'll hang up now.
Thanks again. I'll give you the money and this message.
Okay.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
What have you got invest in our planet while also investing in your financial
future? Think about that. Our resources are diminishing.
Our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest challenges will be tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth companies working towards clean water when
usable energy and green technology.
It's a market opportunity you can feel good about.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your account at swell,
investing.com/radiolab
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab and today. Hello.
Yes. Or as a dolphin might say, how would it often say it? I don't know.
We'll end that. You know what?
That is exactly kind of the question of this next segment.
I mean the dream that a human being and talk to a dolphin or any animal really
get in their heads, cross that gap.
This is a dream that humans have had for since like forever. Yeah,
St Francis of Assisi.
It goes away back now and so far as dolphins are concerned,
after the John Lilly's situation, researchers did get a little tepid,
but they didn't stay tepid as you say, for long.
No, because along came this woman,
Dr Denise Hersey, director of the wild dolphin project,
who basically decided to take John Lily's experiment and flip it rather than
have the dolphin speak English, let's have the humans speak dolphin,
or at the very least let's create a shared language where humans and dolphins
can speak
or at least whistle. Well, you know, it's about finding,
finding a place you can meet back to produce your Lynn Levy. Okay.
So for Denise, this dream of finding that meeting spot,
it goes back to when she was a little girl. Well, when I was 12 years old,
I used to page through the encyclopedia Britannica.
In the days when we had books and I would always stop at the whale and Dolphin
page, look at the dolphins and go, wow,
I wonder what their brains are like.
Cause they've evolved in the water that when you were 12 I was, I was,
I was a total nerd. In fact, I, I entered this contest in Minnesota.
Like what would you do for the world if you could do something?
And I actually wrote,
I would build a human animal translators so we could figure out what was going
on in the minds of animals. So yeah, I don't know.
I got the bug early and here I am. Do you have,
were you having a fantasy about what you might learn or fantasy? None.
I was just curious. So I don't know. You look in their eyes,
there's definitely something behind there. You just want to know what it is.
Fast forward many years,
Denise got a boat and I went out to The Bahamas. She was like,
if I'm going to study these dolphins, I'm going to do it in the wild.
That's where they live. So she tracked down a pod of wild dolphins. Yep. Yep.
And she just tried to blend in.
I actually anchored the boat in one spot most of the time.
This spot in the Bermuda Triangle in the middle of,
I call it the Dolphin highway, where dolphins come and go.
They could come by if they wanted to, and if they didn't, they didn't.
When they would come by,
she and her team would just slip into the water and behave ourselves.
Just sort of watch paying attention to who was who,
which dolphin had a crooked Finn, which one didn't, and when they'd leave,
we'd get out. And that's really how we operated for the first five years.
And it had worked five years.
She spent five years just watching not doing anything else. Yes.
Doesn't just take an enormous amount of patients. Well, sure. I mean,
but after about five years, they started realizing, well,
these guys aren't gonna grab us and pocus and products.
So they started just going about their own business, like feeding, mating,
nursing, and talking
[inaudible]
or at least making a lot of noises,
which she and her team would record. Wow.
That's all dolphin. Well, Dolphin make things. They make all these, yeah,
like that. That's like,
there's like a clicking kind of quaking sound that they make.
That sounds like a zipper. That's pretty, yeah. Yeah.
They make like whistles that are more kind of distinct and then they make them
sound they're like longer and weirder.
And do you have any sense that each of these sounds mean something different?
Well that's exactly what we don't know.
I couldn't tell you what kinds of sounds are correlated with fighting and with
mating or disciplining a calf. What we don't know is,
are there detailed kind of words in there or is there a more kind of encoded
information?
But what they do know is that each dolphin seems to have its own kind of
signature whistle, which is basically a name.
Every individual has its own name. Peter had a name,
nobody's ever asked me that. Here's Margaret again. And his name was
s s
really? It is almost saying Peter here. Right.
So I can call you Lynn by your whistle and knew Robert by your whistle.
It could be a dolphin going, Eh, Lan. Exactly. Do they do that?
They do. Huh? Not only that, uh,
apparently dolphins will use the names of other dolphins who aren't even around.
Like they can't see them. Like they'll talk about each other behind their backs.
Yes, maybe. Wow, good.
That means that they're using representations of things which aren't in front of
them, which is sorta like the beginning of language,
if that's okay they're doing and we don't know.
But if that's what they're doing, then yeah,
that's kind of like the edge of language. So, you know,
it gives us hope that there's probably more information going on there than we
know.
And now finally she has that device,
which device is the
magical, you know,
human animal translator device that she was dreaming of writing about when she
was 12.
She has this box that can generate dolphin noises and it can recognize dolphin
noises. And if it works the way that you know that she's dreaming it all work,
it could be the first like real two way back and forth conversation between a
human and a wild animal.
So we're looking forward to the summer and getting out and getting more data and
really exercising the boxes. And see what happens.
[inaudible] good. We're ready. So I begged my way of board.
Everybody good. See you. Sick pills talking.
We left on July 8th from Florida next month. Yeah.
And headed for The Bahamas to see this pod that she has been following kind of
forever, almost 30 years now.
Hey, hello.
Boat is called the, um,
RV stoneleigh vanilla is the scientific name for this particular type of
Dolphin. The spotted dolphin. Have you seen the spot at Dolphin?
I've never seen one in person.
All right. [inaudible] what
is this boat like? It's like not a tiny boat,
but it's not a big boat and it was just absolutely full of humans.
And who, who is it? Who are your humans? Yeah, well there's Denise obviously.
How's it gone? And you've got a captain. My name is Keir Smith,
first mate and Yo, research assistance. Alison Meyers. Les Mason,
Bethany Oli air, Nathan's script check volunteers.
There's a acoustics expert,
which he has Hoffman for a long time I couldn't even figure out where everybody
was sleeping cause the boat seems so small.
It was like there was not room for all these people on this boat behind you.
There's a soft hot soldering iron next to the fridge and I haven't even gotten
to this guy. Don't get into it.
Ding, Ding Ding.
He, his name is [inaudible].
So you didn't have like any dolphin experience before this, right? Oh Hell No.
He's one of the guys who invented Google glass.
I became a computer programmer so I'd never have to lead air conditioning.
Right. And I'm out here. And what is this a hundred degree weather to do what?
So his job on the boat is to, he's in charge of these these boxes.
This box is probably costs a hundred k at this point.
[inaudible] for funding Louis for funding. So he's the tech Wiz.
When he came down to visit my lab,
I was telling you about the two way work and the difficulty with underwater
stuff and he said Oh I build wearable computers cause how can you build me an
underwater wearable computer that it shouldn't be hard four years later?
What does this machine look like that you looks like when a toaster like one of
those fancy chrome toasters, except you wear it on your chest. Are they silvery?
In fact, they are silvery.
They have a bunch of sort of knobs and buttons and speakers on them.
It's got preprogrammed whistles in it.
I can punch a key and it projects whistle eight here. Whistle beat
here it was the seed.
She's programmed in signature whistles of some of the dolphins, right?
Hello p shoes and [inaudible]
we uh, made signature whistles for ourselves. Oh,
she can call their names and they can call her names. That's,
that's what you're saying. That is the idea. Yeah. And,
and if they do call her name, this name that she's made for herself,
then the box should be able to recognize it and can tell her that she has been
called by name. It'll actually sit say into her ear in English, Denise, Oh,
this is real time. I call it real time sound recognition, but it's real time.
Whistle recognition underwater. How does,
if she's made up this name for herself,
how is it that they're going to know that that's her name? Well,
the idea is that they're learning.
So she gets into the water over and over and she says,
you know the equivalent of hi, I'm Denise. Hi,
I'm Denise over and over and over and they learn it. You know,
they developed this little like maybe they'll just start to use it and call her.
Yeah. So you hope you hope they call you.
I'd be really sad if they didn't call my name,
but Vegas at the very least you could call their names and see how they react.
Right. We'll see. That would be a Eureka moment.
I think if you hit the Lolita button and Lolita suddenly turned and looked right
at you with a shock. Exactly. What the heck? Wow.
That human called me by my signature whistle. Whoa. That, has that happened yet?
It hasn't happened yet
and this is something I just did not appreciate for awhile. I was on the spot.
I was like, why is this so hard? Like this seems like it should be.
These people are so smart, like this should be easy,
but they're just like constantly being defeated by the ocean basically,
which I'm the ocean is like a worthy foe,
but it's like the first year, first year was complete disaster,
trying to get the hardware to work.
What happened the first year everything broke. It was leak city.
Basically the boxes just kept shutting down. As soon as they would get in there,
that's not good. It's not good. That's the sort of not what you want. No,
and last year the box is working, but then we couldn't find the dolphins.
Dolphins just disappeared. You know?
They went a hundred miles away to another location. They don't know why.
I kept up with my side of the deal.
Today's your dolphins stood you up g and one of the reasons I was on the boat is
it felt like everybody was thinking like, this is it.
This is the year we're going to go out there and we're going to find some
dolphins and we're going to make some history.
You Ready?
[inaudible] now.
Any minute now?
Okay. It turns out it's not that easy to find these dolphins.
They're not tagged, you know, they're wild dolphins.
So you just like you go to where you think they might be. You know that song?
Yeah.
You stare at the water and you wait.
Yeah. What is that
for the first three days? Pretty much I would, we were just driving around
in circles, like literally in circles, you know? I feel like I had like a,
like a five hour conversation about game of Thrones.
I've never even seen an episode of game of Thrones, dolphins. Any dolphins,
anywhere. No.
It was nothing else to do at all. Just come on dolphins. We need you now.
Come on. Dolphins. Dolphins come on dog to kick in
bed.
Seaweed. It looked like a [inaudible].
Come on dog.
Oh waive. That looks like a dolphin.
I just say that I would be like,
everything looks like a dolphin to me right now. There are days like that
open. They are right there.
All of a sudden out on the water receive one. Fin Two fins, three fins, five,
six, seven, eight. Oh,
there's so many of them and they're so cool standing
there and watching them. Denise turns to me and she goes, you want to go there?
I don't know, do you recommend it? And I was not prepared for her to say that.
And also I was holding recording equipment and everything and so I just,
I ended up just having to go in like in my clothes,
like wearing like my shorts and like a bra and I like,
I all modesty aside, like thrown aside, they were like, you can go in.
And I was like, oh, okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Go on. Jesus Christ. Here we go.
Um,
we'll be right back. Hello. Huh?
This is Michelle from Honolulu radio lab is supported in part by the National
Science Foundation and by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org mahalo.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing an impact investing platform.
You vote with your dollars when you shop. Well,
what if you could do the same when you invest with swell?
Invest in high growth companies without checking your values at the door.
It's a market opportunity linked to global progress in clean water.
Who are will bill energy medical breakthroughs.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your account@swellinvesting.com slash Radiolab.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and today the show is called hello back to Lynn.
I mean, it's a total sensory shift.
The temperature changes, everything goes quiet.
It almost feels like this, like the classic through the looking glass moment.
Where are you?
Like you go through the looking glass and like everybody's walking on the
ceiling.
And I jumped in and there were two pretty big dolphins coming right at me,
like maybe two feet from my head, um,
and staring at me and I was like, uh,
I don't know. What do you know? What did you do? I stayed very,
still pretty much froze. Now. How far were they from two feet.
Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah. Dolphins are not small.
And they were looking at me in a way that was like, we see you.
And also there they make these um,
sort of clicking sonar sounds, which are like,
they were talking to you or just talking about, well, know what I mean?
What I think they were doing is, is,
is sonar in me sort of looking at me with their, with sound.
I mean my head was vibrating. I mean they can see not just body shape.
They can see your bones. Oh,
they can see into you like you really feel looked at.
Wow. It was heart stopping.
[inaudible]
believeable it was weird.
It was so cool at that point.
It's like the trip
couldn't know and I go home happy, you know? And everybody was like,
calm down. Those weren't even the right dolphins. What do you mean? Well,
those were bottlenose dolphins, Denise studies spots. Uh, but
the next day, all right. Onwards for spots, spots or bust,
we set out again, go for a few hours.
Bethany does this dolphin daily energetic spotted and got some
dance. You saw him, right? Yeah. Right there. Yeah. There we go.
Gotta be spot. So then everybody's like, you know,
it's like all hands on deck situation.
Everybody's like strapping on the boxes and strapping on the headphones,
which is a lot of scrambling. There's so much scrambling. Oh,
there's one off the bow here. It's like a fight. It's like a fire drill.
Now I'm putting on my box. Here's the problem.
I'm just testing. I'm like a captive dolphin. Wild Dolphins.
They have other things to do. They have, you know, fish to catch.
You kind of have to entice it into having a conversation,
otherwise it'll just swim away.
But how do you do that when you don't know its language? Well,
turns out dolphins are just crazy for scarves. Skirt high, uhm,
scarf low. When you throw them a scarf,
they sweep it up with their tailfin and then they let it go and it wafts through
the water and another dolphin comes up and sweeps it up with their rostrum.
So the idea is use the scarf as kind of like a, a bridge.
Denise and another diver will get in the water with a scarf.
We'll get in the water and we'll just start passing it back and forth.
It's human to human. Like, Hey, look at this fun thing. We're doing,
let them watch. If they want to get in the game, we let them in the game.
Sometimes we'll take the toy over to them,
show it to them and press the word for scarf. Say, hey, this is a scarf.
They just made up a whistle for scarf. Yup. And ideally, and this is the key,
the dolphins will pick up the word and use it to,
to ask for the scar if and when they do that,
then you've got like a tiny bit of common ground that you can build on.
Okay. Well you got, we have four spot at Dolphin. Yeah. Little candidates.
Alex. Yes. You've been waiting for them, right? Yeah. Just before they jump in.
Denise walks another diver through the game plan. Oh,
so you're going to hold it and you're not going to give it to them. Okay.
You're going to entice it with them. You're going to be like, oh, this is fun.
It's like dive down with it and like wave it or, yeah,
start at the surface and just really get them with you moments later.
All clear. Good. We're ready.
And East jumps in followed by three other divers.
Where you in the water at this time?
No, I actually had to watch the whole thing from the deck and like you could see
from the surface three or four
adolescent dolphins see the nieces right up next to one of them.
You see the back of her head in her little snorkel. That's good.
She's surrounded right now. What are they doing? Sure.
Oh they're kind of like twisting around each other. I will say this.
She is tremendously graceful in the water.
She gets in the water and she's like totally at home. So maybe she is a dolphin.
She might secretly be a dolphin going like around and around.
And then she goes on there man. What is happening under there?
This is what it sounds like underwater.
This is the actual sound from the scarf dance.
They record everything that goes on under there.
I mean a lot of that is the dolphins just doing whatever they're doing. Um,
but some of it is nice with the box making this scarf whistle over and over.
Like
scarf. You want the scarf? Yeah. Scarf.
Cause she's like trying to get the dolphin to say the word, right?
Yeah.
Eventually she and the dolphins surface and
he's got the scarf. One of the dolphins is holding the scar. Hey,
it's like this flash of red and then they all go back under
[inaudible]
and Denise comes back up with it. That's real good. All right. Wait and see.
After about a minute she surfaces. I think Denise has it now.
She dies one more time.
[inaudible]
a minute later, Dolphin has the scarf and this one on and on.
They were passing it back and forth so fluidly that I thought maybe the Dolphin
has begun to ask for the scarf by name.
Eventually lease gets gravity sucks hauled back up onto the boat
and we all just sort of gather around like, wow, well yeah,
the two juveniles picked up the scarf right away and played some signature
whistles, played some scarf whistles,
and then some Sargassum came flooding by piece of seaweed.
Throw it on that played the Sargassum. Listen, you think you got an mimic?
Nothing that triggered the system, but you know, we'll see what it looks like.
That's exhausting. She didn't get anything. Well, I mean, nothing the box.
Hey guys, as a match, you know,
nothing that indicated the dolphin like learned a word.
Aw.
Sounded like they were right there.
But there was this one thing that happened. She said that when she,
um, addressed one of the dolphins by its name, uh,
the dolphin turned around and looked at her and kind of cocked its little
dolphin head. Really? Yes.
[inaudible] I was hoping you'd say that. Wow.
Also, there was this moment where that,
and Celeste were looking at the data later that,
and they saw that right after Denise made her signature whistle cause that
somebody responding with her seizure was another dolphin made its signature
whistles. Sweet. Oh, that's pretty cool.
You mean like she said hi and it said hi back. Yeah. That's amazing. Well,
maybe, I mean,
the thing is dolphins make their signature whistles all the time.
So it could be nothing or it could be this,
I mean, she's a very rigorous scientist.
Like she wants that to happen another 30 times before even starting to take it
seriously.
But still it does make you think about the possibilities.
What do you want to ask?
I don't know. I want to ask everything. So
[inaudible]
like what? I'd like to know what their lives are like when we're not around.
And then how do you spend your day, you know, do they think about things?
I mean, do they think about the future? Did they think about the past? I mean,
we know they have longterm memories, you know,
do they remember their calves from 10 years ago? Did they think about death?
Yeah. And they certainly see it. Just be anything you'd ask your friends, right?
[inaudible]
although part of me wonders like,
I think we're going to get even get there.
Well that's the goal is to have a conversation and he can't do it this way where
you're in the wild and you can't touch them and you've got to verify every
whistle 35 times. What?
Are they ever actually going to have a conversation because they one of the
language lesson I could, yeah, I get it.
But like don't you feel like Margaret was all the problems
in terms of that experiment aside which she was actually getting somewhere with
Peter? Like they were actually having a real exchange
in the moment perhaps. But thinking forward,
I believe that what you can accomplish by talking,
by having a two way conversation is just infinite.
Yeah, and I totally agree,
but if it's taken her 30 something years to get to a maybe hello?
Yeah, she doesn't even know if she got to hello yet.
And if all she has is a just a limited amount of time with these dolphins every
summer, then 50 more times.
If you can tell your 50 more years and I'm just like, Oh God,
the plant is going to be 17 degrees warmer. By that point,
dolphins are going to have all migrated to some other spot. It just feels like,
Ugh, come on. Just get in the pool and hold. Let, let,
let the Dolphin hold your foot. She's already got the how low going for her.
Maybe. So like a start and then, yes. In 50 years.
Should we have moved past hello to a three word sentence.
How's your macro today? Yeah. I think that two or three word sentence. Yes.
I would put money on a three word sentence in 50 years. The question is,
do we ever get to the point of exploring death? Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know. Lynn, do you have faith
[inaudible] I have faith that if Denise continues with what she's doing,
that we'll be able to talk about concrete things.
We'll be able to talk about seaweed and we'll be able to talk about,
um, coral and we'll be able to have a scintillating conversation about scarves.
I do believe that, and that is not nothing. I mean,
that is pretty impressive in its own way.
Big thanks to our, to our producer.
I'm Jack. I'm Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich. Thank you guys for listening.